another month of summer another batch of
free games for PlayStation Plus
subscribers if you're one of them and
want to know what you can play for free
in August I've got you covered and don't
forget to hit that subscribe button to
be the first to know about the PS Plus
lineup every month
first up ps4 owners are getting Just
Cause 3 the latest game and the
ridiculous
action franchise features the series
largest group of islands ever with
plenty of oceans and mountains and
caverns to explore and don't forget the
signature grappling hook and all those
planes cars and boats you can hijack
speaking of boats ps4 players can also
set sail with Assassin's Creed freedom
cried this standalone epilogue to Black
Flag stars out of wale shipwrecked on
the coast of Haiti during the maroon
rebellion it's a great way to get
hands-on with a fan-favorite character
who've never really got much of the
spotlight ps3 players can check out
snake ball and if you are familiar with
the classic game snake you can piece
together the rest your objective is to
use your snake to roll a ball into the
center goal and thanks to a bunch of
different modes and eight-man
multiplayer there's a good bit of
variety in doing that also coming to ps3
is super mother lode a prequel to 2004
is mother lode it's also all about
digging and the deeper you go the more
minerals you'll find letting you upgrade
your drill and sell the extras back at
base you'll also have to solve puzzles
by planting bombs a new feature for this
particular entry as her PS Vita owners
you'll be getting the sneaky indie game
level 22 Gary's misadventure the stealth
game is set in a totally normal business
office which means you'll have to sneak
around by hiding in closets and crawling
through vents if you've ever just wanted
to destroy the company printer now's
your chance
and finally Vita is also getting the
action game down well you get to dive
into a well blast all sorts of creatures
with your rocket boots collect treasure
and try to combo your way to the bottom
the high contrast 8-bit art style is
pretty sweet too and thanks to cross by
down well is also playable on ps4
and those are your free PS plus games
for August 2017 remember that you can
always check out gameplay and reviews
for these titles over at GameSpot and if
you want to keep up with all of our top
stories you can always grab the official
game spot now app on iOS and Android
[Music]